both laureates have made a crucial
contribution to focusing attention on
and combating such war crimes Denis
McGregor is the helper who has devoted
his life to defending these victims
Nadia
Murad is the witness who tells of the
abuses perpetrated against herself and
others each of them in their own way has
helped to give greater visibility to
wartime sexual violence so that the
perpetrators can be held accountable for
their actions the physician Denis
McGregor has spent large parts of his
adult life helping victims of sexual
violence in the Democratic Republic of
Congo since the poncey hospital was
established in Bukavu in 2008 dr. McKie
Vega and his staff have treated
thousands of patients who have fallen
victims to such assaults most of the
abuses have been committed in the
context of a long-lasting civil war that
has cost the lives of more than 6
million Congolese Denis McGregor is the
foremost most unifying symbol both
nationally and internationally of the
struggle to end sexual violence in war
and armed conflict his basic principle
is that justice is everyone's business
men and women officers and soldiers
local national and international
authorities alike all have a shared
responsibility for reporting and
combating this type of war crime the
importance of
Denis mukwege is enduring dedicated and
selfless efforts in this field cannot be
overrated he has repeatedly condemned
impunity for mass rape and criticized
the Congolese government and other
countries for not doing enough to stop
the use of sexual violence against women
as a strategy and a weapon of war
Nadia Murad is herself a victim of war
crimes she refused to accept the social
codes that required women to remain
silent and ashamed of the abuses to
which they had been subjected she has
shown uncommon courage in recounting her
own suffering and speaking up on behalf
of the victims
Nadia Murad is a member of the Yazidi
minority in northern Iraq where she
lived with her family in the remote
village of kocho in August 2014 the
Islamic state Isis launched a brutal
systematic attack on the villages of the
Sinjar region aimed at exterminating
they RCD population in Nadia Murad's
village several hundred people were
massacred the younger women including
underage children were abducted and held
as sex slaves while the captive of the
ISIS Nadia Murad was repeatedly
subjected to rape and other abuses her
assaulters threatened to execute her if
she did not convert to their hateful in
you
version of Islam Nadia Murad is just one
of an estimated 3,000 year city girls
and women who were victims of rape and
other abuses by the ISIS army the abuses
were systematic and part of a military
strategy
thus they served as weapon in the fight
against your CDs and other religious
minorities after a three-month nightmare
Nadia Murad managed to flee following
her escape she chose to speak openly
about what she had endured and in 2016
at the age of just 23 she was named the
UN's first goodwill ambassador for the
dignity of survivors of human
trafficking this year marks a decade
since the UN Secretary Council
excuse me UN Security Council adopted
resolution 1820 which determined that
the use of sexual violence as a weapon
of war and armed conflict constitutes
both a war crime and a threat to
international peace and security this is
also set out in the Rome Statute of 1998
which governs the work of the
International Criminal Court the statue
establishes that sexual violence in war
and armed conflict is a grave violation
of international law a more peaceful
world can only be achieved if women and
their fundamental rights and security
are recognized and protected in war
this year's Nobel Prize Peace Prize is
firmly embedded in the criteria spelled
out in Alfred Nobel's will Dennis
McGregor and Nadia Murat have both put
their personal security at risk by
courageously combating war crimes and
seeking justice for victims they have
thereby promoted the fraternity of
nations through the application of
principles of international law